i mean let's talk about some narratives
real quick we have this story from
newsweek
uvalde mom who saved kids from school
shooting says police threatened her have
y'all seen the video of the mom who went
in the building
giving an interview and explaining what
happened
i will tell you this the conclusion is
simple either intentionally or
inadvertently police helped the shooter
in yuvaldi yeah that is not with it that
is not being disputed right now so when
people came out and and slammed the
police because they were standing in the
hallway for 70 minutes at this point
everyone said it was incompetence these
people are cowards but then when this
mother says the police actually stopped
her inside and tried and and they tried
stopping her while she was already in
the building you have to wonder
if there were people in the building
trying to get in the classroom this
mother and the police not only were not
going in but they were even stopping her
and others and this only ended because i
believe it was a cbp tactical unit that
defied orders and just breached the
building the cops there
i would presume we're just accidentally
helping the shooter heaven forbid they
knew it was happening and said no no
we're gonna let it roll out nobody would
i'm gonna totally reject that i don't
think that that is what happened but i
do believe that it's gross in competence
i am someone anybody who's watched me
knows that i'm very pro-law enforcement
pro-good law enforcement as i think we
all should be but i don't think there's
any excuse for what happened i'll also
note the u.s marshals lied about this
they blatantly lied about it you know
they denied handcuffing any parents even
though immediately there were videos of
handcuffed parents on the ground this is
may 27th 8 58 am us marshall's official
twitter handle additional u.s deputy
marshals were asked to expand and secure
the official law enforcement perimeter
around the school deputy marshals never
arrested or placed anyone in handcuffs
while securing the crime scene perimeter
that's a lie they tasered parents right
this is the insanity why give also why
give them the benefit of the doubt right
we should about
benefit of the doubt about what they're
saying number one and and two this
entire saga and event uh i think it's
possible
they were waiting for the shooter to to
run out of ammo and they were lying
through their teeth about every aspect
of this it's not out of the realm of
possibility to say that they were aiding
and abetting at this point when we know
all the details here because how long
what's the time frame here why are there
so many unanswered questions about this
very specific event and and this mother
came and said some very important things
that contradicted the official police
story once again they can't get that
story straight they keep lying through
their teeth and when you look at their
actions they arrested handcuffed parents
tasered parents pushed them away set up
a blockade and they told everyone on the
news there was no active shooter it
wasn't an active shooter information why
what information did they have that that
provided that information since there
was kids inside of the school literally
calling them and with the dispatchers
with their radios we're telling them
it's still an active shooter situation
children needlessly died because of
these police officers direct
intervention that killed children this
is not the this is not the truth there's
one child shot bled out died
specifically
40 minutes after 40 minutes there's
another officer that allegedly said said
say something if you're in the room and
you need help said something the killer
shot them this mother came out and she
said two very important things one that
there there was an active shooter
situation that was going on for a lot
longer than the police said it was and
two when she first came in there she
said that there was no police officers
inside but they did try to stop her
outside so what in the world were they
doing
why would they give the orders not to go
in
when specifically they were getting
information from the radio saying it was
still active they said they said that
they thought it was not active what
evidence did they have giving that
information they won't provide that
there needs to be some serious questions
there needs to be some accountability
put these people on a stand right now so
we found out so we find out what
happened because the blood on those
children's hands i mean they're
responsible for it whether you like it
or not and
this this whole back to blue crowd needs
to really understand the true realm of
what happened here because it happens a
lot she real quick she's she's uh the
threat was that she said if she spoke up
she would be charged with obstruction of
justice if she spoke up outside in the
moment after speaking critically about
the incident of the media gomes said an
officer threatened to charge her for
violating probation on an unrelated
charge for obstruction of justice
disgusting abuse of power i mean that
right there shows you that they're
trying to cover up and silence critics
of them
pathetic punks abusing their power fire
all of them right now all of them should
be fired and and they should be
disgusted for their behaviors and i want
to be gusting i want to be very clear
about the back the blue crowd i believe
that the way that this is handled
absolutely was a travesty and a tragedy
i don't believe there's any excuses for
what happened they had a dream now they
had a drill practice saying this weeks
ago i don't believe we have any excuses
and they had an ai program that they
literally had trying to prevent this
they were training inside of that school
days before their shooting march yes yes
march yeah yeah yeah days march 26th
they were training
to prevent and stop a mass shooting and
then their plan in action was stand
outside and and attack and taser
and and handcuff parents this is
what i just want to make clear that i'm
making a distinction about intent i
don't believe there's any officers that
have the intent to allow someone to kill
children intentionally i just want to
make a distinction that i don't believe
that that's what happened i'm not saying
that i don't believe that they their
actions led to kids dying that shouldn't
have died so if the cops are there they
have protocol to storm the building even
if you're a single officer that's what
the protocol said and they all stand
outside for what was it 70 minutes
i i like i think you can argue what you
mean by intent but like
yeah they were they were like okay with
him doing it that's that's the thing
they were okay with it absolutely it's a
fact like you you can't stand outside
hearing the gunshots go off like they
did
and be and like and pretend it's not an
active shooter situation and lie through
their teeth my point is they're standing
outside hearing the gunshots for 70
minutes and they were like no no
yeah that means they were fine with what
was happening inside now i i understand
there's going to be like we can get to a
semantic argument what it means to be
fine sure i'm not saying they were like
high-fiving each other i'm saying they
were like it is preferable for me to
stay here than do anything to help these
kids when it comes to a business that
opened up when walmart was allowed to be
open months before that they were tough
guys they came in there they shut down
grandma's small business a kid wasn't
wearing a mask in school they dragged
them out of school handcuffed them
arrested them in many instances a parent
had a baby that that wasn't wearing a
mask on a plane they were all tough in
the in that time but when it came to
children
children losing their lives calling them
talking to them as it was happening this
is this is what you have to understand
here about this event they were calling
9-1-1 they were talking to their
dispatchers dispatchers were telling
them hey there's kids inside they're
bleeding out they're dying they're still
being continued to shot and the your
decision is like oh it's not an active
shooter situation we're not we're just
going to stand back here well it's in
dispute that the 9-1-1 dispatch calls
were making it to the officers my
understanding is that is in dispute and
there was some belief that the guy who's
now in hiding like didn't bring his
communications in and wasn't relaying it
i'm just saying what i know and what
isn't is not confirmed but i do agree
we're probably semantics i think we're
in the same position that where i stand
on this is officers could have saved
children's lives and didn't now whether
anyone wants to put intent on the
officers i just am not in their brain
and i don't believe that anyone would
intentionally the police officers
felt that it was preferable to remain
outside while they heard the gunshots
and children being killed
they preferred that you can't assume
what they did because we don't know what
they did that's why because they're
lying through their teeth
but but you saying well they're just
they didn't want to get hurt we don't
know that
we we don't know what happened to be
clear that's what i'm saying is i'm not
in their heads and neither are you so
absolutely not but i know they're liars
a lot of this story is has has changed
right my understanding is that cbp the
tactical unit that actually went with
the shields were defying orders was that
is that still yes that's an officer that
showed up there and then him and his
buddy they had a shield that they used
specifically but they waited 30 minutes
they were given orders they got there
and they were told to stand down they
stood down for 30 minutes then after
those 30 plus minutes this is the
official story again everything should
be questioned because these accounts
have been contradicted multiple amounts
of times but the current story is that
they waited 30 minutes and then after 30
minutes then they decided to disobey
orders um and then go in
with the number of officers and a swat
team who is giving orders to allow the
shooter to kill people well isn't it
that guy that now is now in hiding is
that what it was i think so i think he
was the commander so there was a
protocol a single officer was supposed
to storm in at least that's what i read
and again the stories changed but my
understanding was in march they had done
drills the protocol was you actively
engage even if you're by yourself and it
said something like if if the officer
goes down another officer who arrives
will have to just go in yeah which means
there was a commanding officer giving
orders to multiple agencies saying no
let the shooter keep killing children so
the new york times got its hands on the
actual um like training manual and in
there it basically tells officers you
are going to have to engage in sustained
and yes sacrificial
engagement with the shooter and so
basically the training said yeah you
might have to die because these are
innocent lives at risk and so yeah again
i mean i don't know how anybody can make
an excuse for for what has happened and
what happened and i agree with you that
we can't at this point believe anything
that is said about it from the official
source because so much of it has been
proven to be incorrect they have they
have spent hundreds of thousands of
dollars in that small town on riot gear
swat gear
and and they posted you know pictures
which they scrubbed on their facebook
page by the way
of them standing tough and strong with
all of their ar equipment and and all
their body armor but but again where did
all this money go to where of all this
training go to they had direct training
in that specific school and there's
still so many unanswered questions that
we don't know about why was that door
open what happened what was there
now they're saying it was closed how did
he get in there where was the school
resource how did he get here how do you
get the truck how do you get the gun
exactly where did you get all that money
from since he of course was allegedly
you know poor
working at a fast food joint i i mean
there's so many serious questions some
people have said credit cards but the
ammo didn't he have like six hundred and
eighteen-year-olds getting credit cards
it's going to be difficult especially
with no credit score so so
real real quick so i'm sorry uh how many
rounds did he have did it was 600 i have
no idea about that uh i'm questioning
everything all right anyway well my
friend ali bradley who used to work at
fox with me in seattle and is an
independent journalist now she was down
covering immigration at the southern
border when this happened so she was one
of the first people on scene and she
spoke to the shooter's grandfather for
an extended period of time and actually
got some insight that no other outlet
had about where he might have afforded
those um those firearms so he had no
expenses in his life
zero he didn't pay rent he didn't pay
his phone bill he didn't pay anything
and he had been working the fast food
job and also working for his grandfather
had didn't have to put out a dime for
anything at 18. so i think a question
for me is how long had been he been
saving and then also the grandfather
told ali bradley that some of his
equipment that he used for his uh work
some heavy heavy-duty equipment and
stuff like that had gone missing so i
think there's a possibility based on
that that the kids stole it sold it had
been saving money because he wasn't
doing anything with his life people in
the comments saying a thousand six
hundred rounds a thousand six so so
what was season five five six so what
are we looking at five five six is that
that's about about a dollar a dollar
around depends where you get it you
could get it for 50 50 something but i
want to i want to point out i think i
have an answer to this
a lot of people pointed out that four
years ago it was reported that a couple
kids teenagers were arrested for a plot
at the school
however it was reported these were these
kids were not the same kid here it was
different people
they said the attack was planned for
2022.
here's what i think
it's possible those kids weren't the
only ones planning it
and that they got caught and didn't rat
out their buddies or buddy or whoever
else what i'm surprised about is if you
have a bunch if you have if you have a
couple kids who four years prior say in
2022 we are planning this
there it is dude gets a job at 16 he has
no expenses he works fast food and puts
all the money in the bank account all of
a sudden he's got enough money for this
stuff right after two years it sounds
like he ordered the weapon previous
prior to uh before his birthday and then
had it delivered so he could pick it up
two days later
i think it's possible this kid was in on
that plot from 2018 and they didn't
catch him so why didn't police knowing
that have any kind of surveillance
precautions considering they had
arrested kids planning this four years
ago not only that but there was a lot of
warning signs there was the torture of
small animals there was the the cutting
of himself like any hallmark signs of a
troubled person who's going to lash out
and hurt other people there was a lot of
that where did our
multi-billion dollar nsa spying
organization go to that tracks trace and
databases almost every single thing we
do to the point where nsa agents have
collections of of people's personal
wiener art uh that they that they are
are known to share and trade with each
other where is the vast surveillance
state that promised that would keep us
safe from terrorist attacks and mass
shooters that would prevent them if we
just give them a little bit of our money
if we just give up a little bit of our
liberty if we allow them to look in our
phones if we allow them to look in our
in our laptops if we allow them to look
into every personal detail of our life
where is the national security
surveillance state when we need it
supposedly that was supposed to stop all
of these they're nowhere he posted
pictures of dead cats in a bag exactly
what other proof do you need that this
was a troubled crazy individual that has
a history of self-harm and the ability
to harm others thanks for checking out
this segment from the tim cast irl
podcast but if you want to check out the
full show live tune in monday through
friday at 8 pm and if you want more
special access content head over to
timcast.com and become a member your
membership helps sustain this company
keep our journalists employed makes this
show happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there is a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8 pm we'll see you all there
you